albeit a loop palestinian
american journalist who worked for the jazeera
for 25 years was assassinated on
may 11 while reporting from
jenning one of the most prominent voices
in the middle east' who covered
the arab-israeli conflict for decades
was working with a helmet  and a
vest with the word pres in
very large letters when he was
fatally shot in the head just where his helmet did not cover him.
On behalf of this chamber
and the group of socialists and democrats,
I want to convey our deepest
condolences to the family and friends of  the
Palestinian journalist, as well as all
those who appreciated her and valued
her work, we will miss Siren and
condemn this cruel murder with all our might,
but let us not
remain in condemnation or in tears,
we want to ask for explanations and actions
on the one hand, this camera  must request a
prompt
international and impartial
investigation to clarify all the circumstances
in which  produced this heinous act and on the
other hand we also ask that
the violent acts that occurred at his
funeral last weekend be investigated with the same determination because
the images of a coffin on the shoulders of
friends and relatives being attacked by
the Israeli security forces  with
batons and blows they hit our hearts and
we are outraged no one no one should suffer
this inhuman treatment at the funeral of a
family member or a friend it is contrary to
freedom of worship and human dignity
this tragedy is the symptom of
frustration and tension
on the ground that are fueled
by the total lack of progress in the
peace process 74 years after the
creation of the state of israel and the
beginning of the occupation of palestine the
situation of palestinian men and women
in the west bank and jerusalem
This is deteriorating more and more,
especially due to the demolition of houses,
the threat of evictions and the continuous
construction of settlements.  s
our thoughts also go
to journalists and
media workers in a few weeks
I am going to lead a high-
level delegation of our
socialist and democratic group to the Palestinian king, he
concluded by making it clear that the
message we have to convey is
our condemnation  more absolute and that we
need to advance in a genuine
peace process for Israel and Palestine
[Applause]